B Bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Martine vous ne parlez souvt
dede ce qui se dit au caucus dea
cocoalition avenir Québec. Mais
cecela pose aujourd'hui : écoutz
jeje n'ai pas besoin, on imagine
ququ'il a beaucoup de sondages,
j'j'ai pas besoin de magie.
JeJe savais que les gens en
avavaient plus cassé selon mes
dédéputés. Il fallait un
cacalendrier de déconfinement. n
écécoute.
- - Oubliez pas aussi que
j'j'ai un caucus de 74 députés.
DoDonc une fois par semaine,
jeje les écoute et puis
ceces 74 députés-là écoutent les
cicitoyens. Donc j'ai bien vu
dadans les dernières semaines qe
lala grogne, les gens qui étaiet
tatannés, le pourcentage qui
memettaient en question les
cocontraintes augmentait.
EnEncore une fois, au-delà de la
prpression, d'abord, on l'a
totolérée pendant tout le mois e
jajanvier, la pression. Ça aurat
étété facile en janvier pour nos
auautres de dire : on lâche tout
çaça lousse. Mais ça n'aurait ps
étété responsable et ce qu'on
atattendait, c'est d'avoir le g,
cocomme dirait l'autre, de la
SaSanté publique pour être capae
d'd'avoir un plan de déconfinemt
susur une période d'un mois.
- - Je m'appelle jusqu'aux 14
apaprès toutes les mesures.
ToTout reprend.
PaPas de limites pour le
rarassemblement à compter de
sasamedi. Martine, de la pressi.
MaMais sur le goût de ce qui ne
popouvait pas faire cela avant.
- C'est compliqué. Il y avait
dedeux choses. Le fond et la
foforme. Sur le fond il n'avait
papas le choix. La pression de n
cacaucus à la pression des
cocommerçants, la manifestation
auaussi ça compte. On voit qu'ee
esest accumule. On était au
QuQuébec, la province ou dans le
momonde, l'endroit où il y avait
lele plus de mesures. Envoie les
anannonces en Saskatchewan, ils
vovont avoir terminé à la Saint-
VaValentin. Nous on va attendren
momois de plus. Monsieur Legault
n'n'avait pas le choix d'arriver
avavec quelque chose est donné e
prprévisibilité. Quand je parlee
lala forme ça consentait quand
mmême une tension dans ce point
dede presse entre la santé
pupublique et le gouvernement.
D'D'ailleurs, le rôle de chacun
sosont bien campés. Monsieur
LeLegault n'a pas pris les
ququestions qui ne lui revenaiet
papas.
OnOn sentait que ce Docteur
BoBoileau, il a dit : j'ai mes r
unun palier. Les hospitalisatios
ririsquent d'augmenter. On sentt
ququ'il y a eu des discussions i
onont dû être assez serrées sur
jujusqu'où on peut aller dans le
dédéconfinement.
- - Encore une fois, Michel, la
prpression et je ne parle pas qe
dedes manifestations, mais il ne
s's'agit que de parler aux gens
auautour de nous. Il y avait un
dédécrochage. Il fallait être à
pepeu près au même pas que dans
leles autres démocraties de la
plplanète.
- - Oui. C'est clair que les ges
sosont fatigués et tannés. Il y
avavait une tension qui venait
avavec cela. En même temps, on
prpréfère le plus beau plan de
dédéconfinement mais si une
sisixième vague Haribo Maude-
AiAimée, onva to reconfiner. Ce
n'n'est pas un plan absolu. Il
fafaut quand même pas oublier
ququ'il est encore 50 morts par
jojour. C'est énorme. Alors, ou,
ilil accepte actuellement ça
fofonctionne, mais beaucoup de
prpression sur lui.
- - On va parler démarre après.
VoVous ouvrez ce sujet difficil.
MaMais on attend toujours le
rarapport, qui, autour des tabls
susur ces catalans aujourd'hui.
- - Ça fait longtemps qu'on le
sesent venir. C'est-à-dire qu'iy
a a deux conditions de base qui
sosont bien plus importantes que
lala grogne. La première, les
efefforts que l'on fait ne se
trtraduise pas par une réduction
susuffisant des hospitalisation.
OnOn avait constaté parce qu'on
fafait plus d'efforts qu'ailleus
etet on avait plus
d'd'hospitalisation.
DeDeuxième chose, c'est que les
gegens qui se retrouvaient malas
nene sont pas des gens qui sont.
cece sont des gens non vaccicinu
dedes gens qui ont des
cocomorbidités. La moyenne de la
popopulation ne sont pas aux sos
inintensifs. Ces éléments sont
plplus importants pour déterminr
lele retrait déconfinement que a
grgrogne.
- - Je faisais référence Martin,
àà Monsieur Dubé qui dit : j'ai
dedemandé une étude parce que pr
lele décès, on peut les compter
mamais ce n'est pas des décès
cacausés par la cavité de dans a
plplupart des cas. Il faut quand
mmême le dire. Il y a des gens
ququi ont la cavité de qui par
aiailleurs, le décès de d'un
cacancer ou de toutes sortes
d'd'autres maladies. C'est pour
cecela que la causalité n'est ps
didirecte. Dubé dit : j'attends
l'l'étude.
- - Si quelqu'un meurt d'une cre
cacardiaque et est porteur du
vivirus, le certificat de décèsa
didire crise cardiaque et
PaPaxlovid. Mais il y a des chos
ququi ne sont pas Clarey quand e
n'n'est pas clair.
- - On a perdu le compte quand
mmême. Il y en a qui arrive est
mamalade ayant le diagnostic avc
lala cavité : il est devienne ds
cacas COVID et ils utilisent des
lilits COVID alors qu'elles ne
sosont pas entrées comme cela.
PoPour l'étude, cela fait quand
mmême deux semaines qu'on atten.
CeCela tardait.
- - Exactement. Très bien.
OnOn écoute Joël Lightbound
ilil est dit que ça suffit la
jejetée politique contre le non
vavacciné.
IlIl reproche son premier
miministre.
JOJOËL LIGHTBOUND, député, PLC,
LoLouis-Hébert, Qc
- - Je peux pas m'empêcher
dede constater à regret que
tatant le ton que les politiques
dede mon gouvernement ont changé
drdrastiquement à l'aube
lala dernière campagne électorae
etet pendant la dernière campag.
D'D'une approche positive et
rarassembleuse, une décision a é
prprise d'adopter une approche
ququi divise et qui stigmatise.
JeJe pense que cette approche
etet que cette politisation
dede la pandémie risque
dede miner la confiance du publc
enenvers nos institutions
dede santé public, et c'est pas
unun risque à prendre à la légè.
- - Avez-vous pensé de cette
sosortie?
- - Je pense que c'est tout le
cocontraire de ce qu'il dit. Cee
ididée de dire que je vais parlr
dede façon rationnelle et
pepersonnelle d'un sujet, cela e
sese fait pas en politique. On e
pepeut pas aller dans un talk sw
etet dire une confidence. Toutea
popopulation mise au courant qud
tutu as micro sur le nez.
HuHumblement c'est mon idée
pepersonnelle et ça n'a aucun
sesens. C'est une bombe politiqe
dede cela. Ce sont les
coconservateurs qui apprennent
l'l'ensemble des arguments
auaujourd'hui. Ce n'est pas juse
didiscuté comme si tu étais dans
toton salon. Tout ce que tu dis
vavas être repris par
l'l'adversaire.
- - Michel, est-ce que cela
momontre... il dit qu'il n'est s
seseul dans le caucus. Des gens
onont un malaise vis-à-vis la
vavaccination obligatoire.
MMême vocabulaire. Est-ce que
cecela rend compte d'un malaise
plplus profond?
- - Le député, Monsieur Legaulta
paparlé de député, c'est la même
chchose pour les libéraux. Ils
sosont au courant de la grogne.e
ququi est étrange, je rejoins ce
ququi le dit, ce qui si elle est
enen quelque chose de réel, la
popolitisation et l'utilisation
popolitique des vaccins, cela a
cocommencé pendant la campagne
élélectorale pendante après
l'l'ancien directeur des
cocommunications de Monsieur
ChChrétien.
CoComme par hasard ils ont
popolitisé la caisse des vaccin.
CeCe qu'elle dit aujourd'hui n't
papas faux.
- - Martine?
- - C'est mon député.
JeJe suis tombé en bas de ma
chchaise. J'étais très surprisee
vovoir cela, surtout que c'est e
gegenre d'affaires qu'on voit
vévénérer en plus, quand on écoe
sosont pas des presses, on voit
ququ'il était extrêmement bien
prpréparé. Il savait exactemente
ququ'elle disait. Et chaque mot
avavait été choisi et pesé.
QuQu'est-ce qu'il veut?
UnUn coup de notoriété pour son
avavenir? Ce n'est pas clair. Ms
cecela est des choses qui va nos
enen dire plus long. C'est certn
quque quand tu comptes dans ton
prpropre but en politique, il ft
quque tu aimais beaucoup la
sosolitude parce que cela va ête
trtrès dur pour lui, son avenir.
ToTout le monde va se rappeler e
cece coup.
- - Très bien.
- - Il n'y a rien de plus
dadangereux dans ce que Kuske
dédéputé intelligent...
- - Michel, votre sujet préféré.
LeLe détail, comment ça
s's'appelait?
- - Je me souviens pas des titrs
mamais oui j'ai fait un papier.
- - On va mettre la carte. Le R,
grgros projet.
OnOn a beaucoup parlé pour la
poportion René-Lévesque, suréle,
lala RTM qui coordonne les
trtransports en commun Montréal
leles 10 que c'est mal ficelé et
mamal dessiné.
ElElle dit que...
lele REM va allonger le métro
n'n'ira pas se fondre à honorer
BoBongrain. Quelqu'un qui de
PoPointe-aux-Trembles va rester
dadans le train. Il ne va pas
prprendre le métro. La RTM dit
ququ'on veut canaliser des clies
auau métro parce que le REM a
bebesoin d'être financé d'accord
quque ce n'est pas un bon proje.
- - Le plus important dans toute
cecette affaire ses 94 %. 94 % s
ususagers. Très cannibaliser.
UnUn moment donnnné, tous les gs
ququi s'occupent des transportsn
cocommun disent qu'on n'a pas
bebesoin d'un autre lien avec le
cecentre-ville. D'ailleurs,
l'l'agent déleste ne vont papasu
cecentre-ville.
PoPour que le REM soit rentable,
leles gens doivent être dedans e
plplus longtemps possible.
IlIl ne peut pas faire cela
auautrement qu'en cannibaliser n
cece qui existe. Ça n'a pas
d'd'allure.
- - Luc, on va revoir la carte.
IlIl y a quand même un nouveau
trtronçon de Pointe-aux-Trembleà
hohonorer Beaugrand.
QuQue penser du rapport?
- - C'est le gouvernement avait
vovoulu mettre fin au projet ele
n'n'aurait pas agi autrement. Je
nene peux pas imaginer que la R,
çaça ne rentre pas dans la tête.
CeCe n'est pas comme cela que ça
fofonctionne. Deuxième chose, la
réréaction immédiate de Monsieur
LeLegault de dire : c'est à Mme
PlPlante de décider. C'est une
fafaçon de lui mettre sur les
épépaules de la décision, va ête
popopulaire dans un sens ou dans
l'l'autre.
- - Martine? Est-ce que quelqu'n
ququi finalement se dit : on a
d'd'autres chats à fouetter? Ele
nene s'entendait pas entre eux.
- - Ce que le gouvernement dit,e
quque nous on est prêt...
c'c'est le projet de Legault.
EnEn même temps, c'est le projet
ququi fait l'équilibre entre le
trtroisième lien.
IlIl passe d'ailleurs dans les
dedeux circonscriptions de
MoMontréal. Ce que dit Monsieur
LeLegault, il y a 10 milliards r
lala table. Arrangez-vous. Faits
lele projet si vous voulez le
fafaire si vous le voulez pas,
tatant pis.
- - Mais je repense l'question
auautrement. Est-ce qu'elle esta
avavoir un projet structurant?
LaLa RTM prend des chiffres de
202013, des gens qui voyagent,
mamais le projet n'est pas pour
202000 et 30 qu'on le fait?
- - Bien sûr. REM, il y a une
pepension immobilière.
DeDes projets immobiliers vont e
coconsoler dans des stations. Ls
cacalculs font que si tu n'as ps
unune base de personne qui se
prprend au quotidien au centre-
viville, les ajouts ne sont pas
susuffisants pour faire vivre le
prprojet. On parle de 2000
pepersonnes qui partiraient du M
auau lieu de ma voiture. On ne
sasait pas combien de nouvelles
rérésidences vont se construire.
MaMais c'est sur 20 ans. Est-ce
quque Monsieur Legault veut
vrvraiment mettre sa tête là-
dedessus pour 20 ans? Il a jetéa
seserviette.
- - Il n'y a pas de transport ds
l'l'est?
- - La solution est de ne pas
alaller plus loin honorer
BeBeaugrand.
LaLa ligne verte et fonctionnel.
ElElle n'est pas sur utiliser.
C'C'est la chose la plus simpleà
fafaire. On va faire plus de
chchance dans l'est avec cela
ququ'avec le REM char en
coconstruction.
- - Donc une petite pension?
- - Toute la pension qui vont
cecentre-ville et du dédoubleme.
C'C'est la réalité.
OnOn n'a pas besoin de cela.
- - Je me permets d'ajouter
ququelque chose. On dit que ça a
cocoûter plusieurs millions par
anannée aux municipalités et 150
mimillions supplémentaires par
anannée au gouvernement. Cela ft
réréfléchir. Si on fait juste
enenlever les personnes de la SM
etet du trait d'honnêteté pour e
memettre dans le REM et que ça
cocoûte 2 millions par année de
plplus, ça n'a aucun sens.
- - Vous avez passé votre vie à
didire : il faut plus d'accès et
mumultiplier les transports en
cocommun.
- - Pas ce projet.
OnOn n'est pas obligé de faire
unun dédoublement de la ligne
veverte du métro.
ToTout cela pour le même prix ac
dedes traits qui vont passer à m
dedes fenêtres de Radio-Canada.
- - On n'est pas regardants pour
cecela.
- - Je vais ajouter quelque
chchose...
lele dédoublement, c'est cela qi
cocoûte cher.
IlIl y a un modèle économique qi
nene fonctionnait pas. Cela ne
pepeut pas marcher. Michel a
raraison. Il faut arrêter à la
ststation honorer.
- - Je reçois la mairesse de
MoMontréal au Téléjournal à 18
heheures et j'ai hâte de le
ququ'elle pose la question.
EsEst-ce qu'elle se contenterait
dede la pension jusqu'à honorait
BoBongrain?
MoMonsieur Legault politiquemen,
c'c'est le genre de Montréal ne
s's'entende pas, il n'avait pas
susur le parquet là-dedans.
- - C Montréal, le troisième li,
cecela fait son pendant près C
MoMontréal a vu, si la mer est
plplante vu ce projet, c'est
mamaintenant. On est en année
élélectorale. C'est maintenant
ququ'il faut qu'elle s'arrange
popour que Monsieur Legault se
cocommette
- - Merci beaucoup. C'est
inintéressant. Vous connaissez s
trtransports en commun beaucoup.
MeMerci beaucoup. On se reparle
bibientô